finding dory as Pixar's latest sequel
and not one that I was really looking
forward to I wasn't overly pumped for
this movie I like the first one it's
good enough I had the blu-ray I think
it's a fun movie and I think it's really
well animated so in extremely forgetful
fish named Dory with short-term memory
loss is trying to find her family she
has these very fragmented memories of
her past broken up memories of her past
are scattered around her brain and she's
trying to find where her parents are
with the help of Marlon and Nemo this
movie really surprised me this is an
extremely fast-paced movie that really
never had a dull moment
there was never a part of this movie
that lacked everything was always
happening it was constantly funny I was
really genuinely surprised by a finding
Dory I had not a single bit of
anticipation for this movie it didn't
look that great to me Pixar has a
history of making trailers that really
aren't all that good and it was the same
with finding Dory the trailers for this
movie did nothing for me but the film
was really great Ellen DeGeneres is so
good as Dory this is an example I'm
going to use for years to come of a
perfect melding of voice actor and
character when I see them on the screen
it just it works it feels real it feels
like a real little fish and there isn't
really anything about it that seems like
it could be different and I can't really
imagine another voice coming from that
character I was afraid she was gonna get
annoying you know constantly forgetting
things needing to be reminded all the
time but it didn't happen
it was always clever and they found
really funny and smart ways to make her
disability she deals with extremely
entertaining but also heartfelt in just
the right ways because it's not too
sappy it's not overly cutesy it's a
smart film kids can really enjoy for its
beautiful animation and for how
fast-paced it is but adults are also
going to find things to like too and not
just smart jokes but the fact that it
doesn't pander to kids it's an
intelligent movie and there are
characters in the film that go in very
different directions and you would
expect them to from their introduction
like this octopus I don't want to spoil
it for you but it really it was great
actually it was really charming and
there's something about this movie that
was just extremely sweet and not in a
way that makes you feel icky you know
like oh it's just really
you know I was kind of sticky the
mixture of emotion and humor and action
sequences as well was really great and
there are so many good characters in
this movie like this introduction to
this whale shark that's something that
Pixar does really well when they're on
point great characters and this movie is
filled with them and I genuinely
actually wanted to know like what is
going on with dory where does she come
from
and the film really nudged me into that
desire wanting to know more about Dory's
past I genuinely didn't think she would
be a very compelling character and I was
wrong this movie was a lot of fun there
is one thing about this movie that is
really almost unprecedented especially
in animated kids films that I can't stop
praising there really isn't a villain
there's no big evil person that wants to
cause harm to someone the situation I
guess is the antagonist of the movie but
I found that to be a giant big breath of
fresh air from a storytelling standpoint
I got to really commend the writers
because that's hard to do to have a
movie that's this compelling with
characters that are this compelling
without there being you know a Darth
Vader every other scene as for flaws
it's really tough to pick one out
because the film is so fast-paced and
fun that the only flaw I could really
find with it is that it perhaps isn't as
emotionally stirring as it wants to be I
didn't find myself crying at key moments
I found myself enjoying the film but I
think the only issue I have with it is
that it isn't quite as emotionally
amazing as I think it should be certain
moments where you should really feel
like the tears are welling up for me
that just didn't happen like it did an
inside-out or Toy Story 3 I thought
finding dory was very good and I'm gonna
give it an A - so guys with fish movies
coming out right now like finding dory
and the upcoming the shallows with Blake
Lively I thought it would be really fun
to fill in the gaps of the jaws films
that I've never reviewed I've already
reviewed the first jaws many years back
as well as jaws of revenge and with jaws
2 & 3 coming out on blu-ray just this
last Tuesday my friend and I actually
had the opportunity to watch jaws 3 in
3d for the very first time so I thought
it'd be fun to fill in those gaps I'm
going to do it slightly in a reverse
order since I've already done the other
jaws movies in a weird reverse order I'm
going to have a jaws 3d hilarious
you for you this weekend with my good
friend Matt Brando he's going to join me
you may remember him from the review I
did the other side of the door and then
after that we're gonna review jaws -
together totally out of order but who
cares it's fun fish movies sharks yes
good also I want to let you know
that I'm still doing my promotion with
audible.com if you go to audible.com
slash Chris you can get a free 30-day
trial of audible they have so many
amazing audiobooks on their website
hundreds of thousands it's unprecedented
in regards to audiobooks you can
download them to your mp3 player your
computer your iPad you can listen to
them on the go anywhere you want to if
you're like me and you sometimes don't
always have the time to pop open a book
and read that book and maybe you're at
your job and you have the ability to
listen to a book and you want to
audible.com is a great source for people
who love reading but don't always have
the time to physically read it's awesome
a lot of people have thanked me for that
service it's a free 30-day trial
check out audible.com slash Chris and
thank you to audible for continuing to
sponsor my videos it means a lot guys
thank you so much as always for watching
look forward to this weekend review of
Jaws 3-d that's kind of fun trust me it
is you guys are the best and as always
if you liked this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
you